Bartholomew Henry Allen that's not a
good name look are you sure I don't go
bark you can bark feels more natural to
me
can we go with Bart bars kind of cool
hey everybody we got some big news
there's stuff going on with the
arrowverse Titans so this is gonna be an
update video for what's coming back what
they're doing with the schedule it's
really all good news all around so no
worries they've clarified when they're
going to announce that they've renewed
all of the shows so I'll try to explain
everything starting with Titans but if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
there'll be more new flash ring giveaway
stuff at the end of this so Titans
what's happening right now is that
they're still in the thick of filming
episodes they film right up until the
end of April early May I think is when
they finish filming their finale there's
supposed to be 13 episodes in season 1
so the cast is basically going back from
their winter hiatus pretty much
everybody in Hollywood gets at least a
couple weeks off for the winter holiday
the latest Titans video that we have is
just Alan Ritchson who plays Hawk on the
series being silly getting ready to go
to the set a murrain deer because it's
30 below outside and I'm gonna go
running it Rangers don't die like I'm a
mittens rate their blood baby
nope nope alright this is it
the lake is frozen all the fishies die
tote six both fatal flaw
we can't go the freezing six era so the
bill suggested i buy windbreaker
underwear if it's not icicle
did somebody google eyeballs freezing
again I gotta know if eyeballs is freeze
pretty sure it's happening more than
halfway through ain't died yet my
muscles are frozen
oh these must be their soup soup
oh that's a slowly he'll be fun to see
is the hawk character but the funny
thing about this like he you know he's a
funny guy in real life
Hank Hall in the comics is very severe
so it'll be fun to see the dichotomy
between what he's like on screen and
what he's like behind the scenes what
are you doing you pulled us right out of
battle she just saved our lives
Hank two yards we have done that but a
lot of you may have started to notice
how much the main actors on Titan's in
the air over shows look like each other
so hopefully if they ever let the
streams cross over they will make as
many multiverse jokes as possible so
it's almost like the Titans are
alternate earth versions of the
arrowverse characters but as they then
the last couple of weeks they'll
probably rule out another costume reveal
for one of the Titans characters so
there's either Raven Beast Boy or
Starfire but I don't think we're gonna
see Starfire or Beast Boy for a little
while because so much CG goes into their
looks best bet is that Ravens the next
comic book costume we see I don't think
they're gonna drop a trailer for it for
a little while but they do have enough
footage to cut a trailer I think they're
just waiting til they get most of the
episodes done so they can just cherry
pick what footage they include moving
into flash season 5 DC TV for next
season for the most part everything is
going to be the same the nights that you
watch it on will be the same they said
that they haven't altered any of their
storyline plans even though they fired
the showrunner from flash and Supergirl
for some reason people were confused and
thought that that was Geoff Johns Geoff
Johns is not the showrunner on the flash
now they didn't confirm how quickly
they're gonna make a beeline for the
other big speedsters from the flash
family that they haven't done yet like
Bart Allen everybody wants to know about
like the really big stuff that they're
sitting on right now there was a video
that I did a little while ago that I'll
link at the end of this where I talk
about the titles for the next couple of
flash episodes that implies that they're
going to be doing Hypertime which is
more multiverse timeline based stuff
visitors from another earth oh there are
more than one
fifty-two actually I'm hard-pressed to
think of one we're not these are
ascendant I can there's a fifty third
earth and it's called Earth X so we'll
actually have a much better idea for
what season five is going to look like
by the time we get to say like Episode
fifteen it's still a little too soon to
know how quickly they're gonna go to
stuff like Bart Allen because even
though I am a hundred percent sure that
they will get to all that stuff
eventually it's just that if the TV show
is gonna go to like ten seasons you just
wonder whether or not they're gonna save
that for the last couple of seasons or
they're gonna go there really quickly
because that's really the whole reason
to get Barry and iris married this soon
so that they can have kids so that you
can do your big Bart Allen reveal the
only thing that we know for sure is that
this actress is coming back and she
seems to be related to Barry like I keep
calling her dawn ala just because that's
my top pick but it hasn't been confirmed
that that's who she is
only that she's coming back and it'll
have something to do with the flash
versus the thinker of the trial of the
flash and whatever their two-part
episode is gonna be this season have we
met no no I'm a complete and total
stranger good luck up there remember to
say I do right okay and I know you
probably have questions about what's
going on in the future of arrow
Supergirl legends of tomorrow there's a
little too much to fit that all into one
video so I'll be doing separate videos
obviously for DC TV stuff so I'll try to
work all that in everything comes back
on the fifteenth so for people that are
upset with the look of Brainiac on
Supergirl the actor actually just came
out and said that his appearance changes
over the course of the episode he's like
I get better-looking as the episode goes
on so he might wind up being the green
skinned version from the comics so what
you're seeing here is not the final
version but everything comes back on the
15th so there'll be TV trailers next
week so I'll follow up with Legion of
super-heroes flash season 5 stuff just
leave all your requests in the comments
below
but arrow Supergirl legends of tomorrow
all that stuff will be coming back for
next season but like the CW executives
said they'll just confirm everything in
a couple weeks but for the most part
they did say
they plan on bringing everything back so
no worries if you were wondering whether
or not stuff was cancelled whether it
was renewed but leave all your questions
in the comments below and I'll just add
them to my next DC TV video but there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
or Legion ring if that's what you guys
want either one doesn't matter all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
share the video using the YouTube tools
on the watch page there and I'll say
congratulations to the winner from my
last DC video Cody macadam please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here for more new
flash and click here for the trailer for
that Superman prequel Krypton which is
coming in March thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight